- All right, good morning.
I think it's still morning.
Appreciate everyone joining.
Welcome to AWS re:Invent.
My name is Anita Mikus,
and I run the Government
and Education market
for Kyndryl in the US.
Wanna welcome you here.
Thank you for joining our session.
We will be talking about
AI-native enterprise today.
We've got a pretty cool
lineup in terms of format.
First, I'll be talking about
how AI and Kyndryl are partnering
to help the public sector experience.
And then we'll weave into a fireside chat
with a couple of special
guests to talk more about
how AI is helping the student experience.
So I wanted to start with a quick poll.
Hopefully you guys can hear me.
First question, how many
people are articulate
and fully understand the difference
between generative AI and agentic AI?
(audience chattering)
Okay, good.
All right, and how many
people are using AI today
to solve their business problems
or maybe personal problems?
(audience chattering)
All right, good.
So my hope is that by
the end of this session,
you've learned a little bit more about AI,
and specifically, how we can leverage
and how you can leverage AI
to solve some of your business challenges.
So as we look at the public sector today,
and especially in the state
and local government space,
there is a huge disparity
between what the public expects
and the services that are
offered by public agencies.
Over 50%, actually, 53% of citizens say
that they are frustrated with
accessing public systems.
And I think about my own experiences.
I can, on Sunday night, order
my groceries on my laptop
with a click of a button.
I can get a ride to here
with an Uber or a Lyft
app within a minute.
But I think about, "Oh my gosh,
I gotta figure out the
status of my state taxes.
I don't know where to start."
"I gotta go get my transcripts
from 1992 when I graduated.
That's gonna take a
whole day for me to do."
So it's really just a
huge disparity between
what people are used to
receiving in the private sector
versus the public sector.
And that's really something
that we all need to work on.
In parallel, there is a 80% use of funds
by the state and local government entities
on maintenance and operations.
That means old systems.
That means we're not talking
about moving the needle forward,
we're not talking about modernization,
we're not talking about transformation.
We are literally spending a
majority of our taxpayer dollars
to maintain legacy systems.
And what this means over
time is increased cost.
It means that you have less resources
that are able to staff the functions
to maintain your legacy systems,
and eventually you may end
up having security issues
and exposures.
So this is where we intersect
between the challenge
and the opportunity.
How do we leverage AI
in our core operations
to help us to reduce support costs,
to increase stability,
to help security,
and ultimately deliver a better experience
for citizens and for
students in universities?
I wanted to share a couple
of examples of areas
that Kyndryl has worked to leverage AI
and to create some pretty nice outcomes.
First one is in Stockton, California.
Kyndryl helped deliver the
city's first public-facing
AI-predictive dashboards,
which provides 320,000
residents real-time insights
into road safety and
estimated repair times.
In a large Midwest city in the US,
we've modernized the parking
and citation management systems
with an AWS AI-powered
omni-channel contact center,
try to say that a few times,
reducing wait times for up to 20%.
So this means how much time
people stay on the phone
or wait for information
or updates to understand
how they can continue with their day
in citation management.
And at UCLA, which we'll dig into deeper
during our fireside chat,
we have worked on digitizing
over 2 million paper records
and laying the foundation for
AI-driven student services.
So at the core of all of these examples,
where we have leveraged AI
to improve the experience
is Kyndryl's AI Framework.
When we talk about AI,
and native AI specifically,
we're talking about baking AI
into the core of operations,
not as a project, not as a pilot,
but embedded in every
single thing that we do.
The Kyndryl Agentic AI Framework,
sorry, the Kyndryl Agentic AI Framework
includes three main components.
The first one is ingestion of data.
It enables the capture of structured
and unstructured data
from diverse sources.
So think about source code
to help us with understanding
what are the dependencies,
what are the relationship
with your source code?
Think about security and IT policies.
When we create agents,
making sure that they're within the realm
of what we consider to
be the safe standards.
Think about policy and procedure guides.
How do your operations run?
What do we do? What are the opportunities?
What are the bottlenecks?
The second is the agent builder.
And this deploys intelligent agents
for specific business functions.
The agents can automate
tasks, make decisions,
and ultimately, adapt based on context.
The third component is the agent catalog.
And this is where the magic happens.
It's a centralized repository
of reusable AI agents
that enable us to scale
by deploying repeatable models
across the organizations.
Together, these elements help us to go to
and evolve into a proactive
AI-native operating model.
So I wanna share with you a short video,
which I guess I'm gonna be doing too,
around how Kyndryl has helped with AI
in a client setting.
All right.
It's not working.
- Yes, it was.
- Oh, it was?
- Yeah.
- Okay, hold on.
(audience chattering)
- Press the link.
- Play.
- (indistinct)
- Enter.
Now it's-
- Good.
- Yep.
- Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- Just press it-
- One time.
(bright music)
- You got it.
- [Anita] I'm in tech.
I'm an IT expert. (laughs)
- The car rental industry
has been completely disrupted
by the likes of Uber and Lyft
and faces existential crisis.
The crux of the issue
with these legacy rentals
are their rigid pricing engines,
which are hard to change.
This has resulted in declining
revenue year over year,
and major operational
efficiency challenges.
We are partnering with
a major rental customer
to fundamentally reimagine
their pricing engine
using agentic AI.
The Kyndryl Agentic Ingestion
Tool analyzes dependencies,
extracts embedded business rules,
and creates a modernization roadmap.
This step transforms static legacy logic
into structured human-readable format.
We use the outputs from ingestion
to automatically generate
comprehensive tests
and modern code.
The outcome is a flexible
microservices-based architecture
that supports modular
components like fleet,
customer, pricing, and ERP integrations,
all designed to work independently
but seamlessly together.
The result is a cloud-native
API-first environment
that accelerates innovation,
simplifies integration,
and gives us the agility to
evolve with business needs.
Finally, we are evolving
the pricing functionality
to a dynamic system.
This involves three distinct agents.
The first agent ingests
multiple external sources,
such as weather insights
and flight patterns,
to come up with probabilistic pricing.
The second agent runs
Monte Carlo simulations
to understand the implications
of various pricing scenarios
on revenue and fleet utilization.
And the third agent
performs compliance checks
based on state and federal guidelines.
This modernization program
is set to deliver a
state-of-the-art dynamic pricing,
just like ride sharing platforms
where prices adjust in
real-time based on demand,
availability, and external factors.
(bright music)
(audience chattering)
- Okay, hopefully that
helped to drive home
the Kyndryl Agentic AI
Framework a little bit more
in terms of how it works in action.
So I'd like to shift
gears a little bit now
and invite two incredible
leaders to the stage
for a fireside chat.
As mentioned earlier,
Kyndryl has partnered
with UCLA Anderson School of Management
to reimagine the student experience.
I'm excited to invite Howard Miller,
the CIO for UCLA Anderson
School of Management
to share more about this transformation
and how it's helping students at UCLA.
And I would also like to
invite Kyndryl's Chinh Vo,
Vice President of Innovation
at Scale for the US.
Alright, well welcome, folks.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, so Howard, I'm
gonna start with you.
- Cool.
- As a pioneer of AI,
both as a person and as a CIO
and also UCLA being a pioneer of AI,
what are the things that inspired you
or compelled you to start you
on your native AI journey?
- Wow, I mean, this is a long story
and we only have a certain amount of time,
so I'll try and keep it relatively brief.
I think it starts with a
conversation with my dean
almost three years ago.
We're at that three year mark
when ChatGPT first became
something that we all knew
and heard about.
And he said to me, "Howard,"
he said, "I put my final into
ChatGPT and it got a B plus.
You know, what's our value premise here
in higher education?"
And you know, it's not
as draconian as it seemed
at that time.
And over that course
of the next 12 months,
what we did at UCLA Anderson is
we decided that we wanted
to be an AI thought leader
as a school.
We formed an AI task force,
which was cross-functional
between faculty, staff, and students.
This was September of 2023.
We started to ideate on things
that we thought might make
sense for us as a business.
We got to the end of December 2023,
we found a platform that we liked.
We found a cost that made sense for us.
We pitched it to the dean,
and I said, "Is this something
that the school wants
to go forward with?"
He said, "Yes."
So two months later, we were
working with some consultants.
We had a platform, and
then two months later,
ultimately, we had our first
two production use cases.
So it's kind of a labor of love.
It's not something that
you get to overnight.
I think I'd highlight the importance
of having a cross-functional
group of people to get together
and help you set that direction.
I would encourage you, if
you haven't started already,
and I saw by the show
of hands that many have,
but for those who haven't,
it's not too late.
I think it's okay to fail fast.
I think you want to find things
that are quick time to value,
so don't try to boil the ocean.
And try and find things
that really have meaning
for your business.
So AI is a great technology.
It's the most transformative
technology I've seen
in 35 plus years working in IT.
But at the end of the day,
you still have to marry
back to business outcomes.
- Yeah, so I think this
is a great example of
how AI can help educational institutions.
And as we start to see some
funding cuts potentially,
this is a great method.
So next question, Howard, is challenges.
What sort of challenges did you face
and then specifically how
did you overcome them?
- Sure, so, you know, truth be told,
there are always gonna be
challenges along the way.
Specifically with the work that we did
with Kyndryl in the app that we built,
one of the biggest
challenges is this is one
where we decided to attack student data.
And so I already told you about the things
that are quick time to value,
and if you wanna go to sensitive
and confidential data, don't start there.
But with the work that
we did with Kyndryl,
we decided that we wanted
to attack student data.
I'll get more into the app
that we built in a little bit.
But to do so, there were a ton of hurdles.
In addition to just institutional
organizational change management,
so in other words, convincing somebody
at the center of campus
that we could go ahead and do this
and follow third-party risk management,
we wanted to ensure the
security and privacy
of that student data.
So we took extra care to
architect that environment
such that it mirrored the
Information Security Policy
of the UC system almost line for line
so if it was ever gonna get audited
that it would pass that test.
So there were definitely challenges
around the data security,
the data privacy.
Culling together all of the data
that we put into this application,.
we took from a lot of
different disparate systems.
We took from the
student's record database,
we took from our career placement,
we took from our clubs,
we took from our course catalog.
So culling all of that together
to put that into one application
in one environment in one engine,
definitely there was some labor of love
that was associated with that.
And then just lastly,
at the end, having a user interface
and being able to approach it
with something that a student
might ultimately want to use.
And that was the compelling
part of this application
to begin with, right?
At a two-year graduate
school of management,
our students come in very quickly.
They're not there for very long.
We inundate them from the beginning.
They start in the summer
before classes even start in the fall.
We send them a ton of email.
They're starting to
interview for internships.
They're doing their coursework.
Some of them still don't really know
what they want to be when they grow up.
And so on top of all of this,
we just say, "Good luck," right?
And there are career advisors,
there are things to
help them along the way,
but the application we
built was really meant
to be a roadmap.
So if you came in
and you said you wanted to be
a product manager at LinkedIn,
or you wanted to work here,
we could give you some kind
of prescriptive path to say,
"If this is what you want to do,
you should take these courses.
You should look at these
companies for internships.
You should join these clubs."
And ultimately, these companies
are the like companies
that follow that roadmap to
where you ultimately
wanna go to be successful.
So all of that was part and
parcel of the challenges
along the way.
- So one thing we've
talked about is the rate
and pace of technology
and how fast it's moving.
We started this project with you,
I think it was December of 2023.
We finished around August of 2024.
So one of the things that
I think about a lot is
what would you do differently
or how would you approach
this project differently now
versus when we started
and embarked upon it
a couple of years ago?
- Sure, I think I would
have, as I said earlier,
I think I would have failed
faster to begin with.
I think we spent so much time trying
to get the architecture right
that by the time we launched,
the technology had changed so much
that not putting
something out there sooner
and getting it into people's hands
and going back and reiterating on that
was probably the biggest mistake we made.
- Yep, got it. Okay.
Chinh, over to you.
So from your vantage
point leading agentic AI
for Kyndryl US,
how do you see organizations
approaching AI,
are customers ready to become AI native,
or what trends are you seeing?
And I know you're just three
or four months into Kyndryl,
so welcome.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Appreciate you.
- Three or four months
into Kyndryl, but I've been in
this for quite a while there.
So actually a lot of the
trends that I'm seeing is,
it's sort of reflected
in Howard's story there.
So especially in in
education, institutions,
and government agencies there,
you know, the promise of
sort of the value coming out
from the generative AI
when ChatGTP came out,
you know, that's sort
of just the reactive way
of actually engaging with it
to the progressions to
agents acting independently
to multi-agent systems
through the agentic
workflows we have today.
You know, in each step
there, the value is there.
And I think that the excitement
in each of these, you
know, sectors is there
and it's palpable.
And to Howard's point,
actually my oldest daughter,
she's a junior this year.
But last year, even as a undergrad degree,
she used it in a field
where it was emerging.
It was an arts program
combined with data science,
machine learning, and computer science,
because they're trying to really do
that creative aspect to things.
But with that, the university
was just building this program on the fly.
Now, imagine having
someone going through that,
planning a course load
and things like that
as the things are
changing at the same time.
I can tell in personal experience,
it was hard and a lot of work there.
Now, if we actually had a
system that Howard describing
just for that purpose there,
it would have saved both her experience
and even the faculty's experience
actually doing this there, right?
So the value is there.
So what's stopping all of this here?
And I think the two main points,
it was really highlighted.
One is data, the other one is trust
on that side of things there.
So on the data side, where
Howard started his journey,
I think from a technology
perspective there,
there's a lot of solutions out there on
how we can actually speed
up that process both from,
you know, cleansing the data
to accessing the data in place
as opposed to moving
into one location there.
That can really hit your timeline there.
The second aspect of it is trust itself.
First of all, all the
policies, audit trails,
and you know, the things
that Howard described,
it's not just an education.
It's the same thing in government agencies
and things that we have to do there.
Then having the idea of an
autonomous agent just interact
with this data, it scares
a lot of corporations
and our customers there.
And so I think the trend
that we're seeing now
as we're moving through
that is actually services
that's gonna actually
address those issues.
If you just noticed the
recent announcement from AWS
for all the AgentCore services there,
from making sure that the agents
are accessing the right tools,
on policy engines there
and making sure the agents are doing
what they're supposed to be doing,
and then observability
aspect to it, right?
In terms of making sure that,
Howard was saying,
do we actually know what an
agent's doing at all times?
Can we actually see that
audit trail around that?
So I think the change is
the foundation to that,
it's supporting that, it's allowing us
to get to that trust aspect of things.
And then lastly, just
wrapping all around there,
it's all the soft stuff around it.
Any transformation we see,
you have people side of things.
How do we actually work
for the consumers of this
and also the providers of this.
Their process isn't gonna change,
and we got to figure out how that works.
And then also
the business process
optimization piece of it there.
So there's a lot of things
that comes into play there.
- Yeah, so I think my next question
is probably applicable to both of you,
so please feel free to weigh in,
but when we do any sort of
large transformation project,
bringing our people
with us is so important.
You talked about trust.
I think Chinh from your perspective,
I'd like to hear what do
you think is so important
about OCM, Organizational
Change Management,
when you're doing a
significant AI transformation
in your organization?
- Yeah, I think if I break
down actually my job role,
you can see that my role
is Innovation At Scale,
which is a little ambiguous
there what it actually is.
It actually encompass major functions
to help our customers adopt AI.
And it's actually the data AI practice,
which is that says for itself is required.
Our enterprise strategy, technology,
architecture side of things,
people and performance,
that's the OCM performance
side of things there.
And then the vital,
which is the user
experience side of things.
If you think about what
I've just described there,
we need all of it to actually
do this successfully.
And that OCM or change
management piece is still central
and core to it.
So all that is actually under my umbrella
because we have to work together actually
to make sure that adoption's successful.
- Thank you. Okay,
question for both of you.
So Howard, oh, whoa, we'll start with you.
How do you see the
landscape of AI changing
as we move forward?
What are the things that you'll do?
How can you manage-
- I'll go back
to the landscape in a second.
- Yeah, okay.
- Chinh said something
that made me reflect on the answer
to the question that you asked.
And when we started this project,
the ability to get at data was somewhat
of an issue, right?
- Yeah.
- So you said we had to take
all of that data that we had
and we put it in one place.
And to the question of where AI is going,
now, we wouldn't have to do that.
- Yep.
- Right?
The ability to integrate
into so many different things with AI
is one of the bigger changes
maybe in the last six
to nine months
- Absolutely.
- that would have certainly made my,
you know, journey with this
application a little different.
So I wanted to highlight that
because I think it does speak to
how quickly things are changing
and how it's difficult for us
in the seats in which we're in
to sort of predict what's next, right?
And so you've talked about
your agentic AI framework,
I'm looking at tools that do low-code AI
with agent builders,
no-code AI, which is just drag and drop.
I think we're all trying to figure out
what agentic AI can mean
for us organizationally.
Again, for UCLA Anderson, it's sort
of this fail-fast approach.
I have a couple of
things that are agentic,
I'm not gonna say they're the sexy,
what everybody thinks agentic
AI should be at this point.
I have an agent that
can call another agent
and it can successfully do that,
handoff such that the person
who's going from agent one
to agent two can then go into agent two
and do specifically what they want,
so it all doesn't have to
be done under one hood.
And the reason for that approach again
is building blocks, foundational.
Again, if you try to architect something
so large at the beginning,
you stand that chance to fail.
By putting those building blocks together
in a very measured way
as part of that journey
is sort of how we're approaching it
and how we're gonna get there next.
I think we're gonna be in
this agentic AI phase myself
for at least the next nine to 12 months.
I know 2025 was supposed to
be the year of agentic AI.
2026 will probably still
be a year of agentic AI.
But I think the ability to have agents
that call other agents
that actually can deliver
on business outcomes
without scaring away the humans
who think their jobs are gonna be replaced
is ultimately sort of
where we wanna head next.
- Okay, thank you. And
then Chinh, same for you.
Where do you see the future of AI
for enterprises going in
the next 12 to 18 months?
- Yeah, I think it's gonna build on.
I think we're got to get to a point
where the discussion of agents
as part of an enterprise
is not gonna be a question anymore.
It's gonna be a reality
that we're gonna have to
account for and plan for there.
And I think the patterns and trends
and architectural approach
is gonna help support that.
It's gonna be driving that.
I actually look back at how
we'd look at compute services.
If you remember, we went
from virtualizations
to containerizations to serverless.
At this point in time there,
I think no one is questioning the fact
that we can run enterprise
critical systems on AWS
and any of those with
the compute services,
which was not the case when
we were first starting.
And I'm seeing the same trend
in the AI side of things
with the architecture
support of that piece there.
And I think the framework that we have,
like our Kyndryl Agentic Framework,
it's a very lightweight framework,
and to address Howard's point,
we're not heavily investing
any particular tech stack side of things.
We know three months from now,
six months from, 12 months,
it's gonna change.
Something's gonna come up.
We gonna have to make sure
that it can adapt properly
and pick that up really
in an efficient manner.
And I think that's where we're gonna go.
It's these sort of lightweight frameworks
where we can adapt change
and actually just pick
up the latest trends
as it comes along.
- Great, well, I wanna thank you both
for sharing your comments
- You're welcome.
- and your perspectives.
I think a few things that
are really important is,
you know, the criticality of the data.
Making sure that we have clean data
and then it's used in the
way that is intended to.
Understanding outcomes.
AWS always talks about working backwards.
I think we're all here trying
to solve business problems,
and we have to look at
what is the business problem
we're trying to solve,
and then work backwards.
I think involving people,
both of you mentioned having
to bring your people with you
to make sure that when you go
through this transformation,
they understand the what, the why,
and the what role they play.
Howard, you mentioned
iterating, right? Fail fast.
How do you make sure that
whatever you're building
at the end of it isn't
not what you expected?
So really just making
sure that we iterate.
And then I think both of
you talked about trust.
Really making sure that there's trust
as you build these new systems.
So as we wrap up our session,
I can't change the screen, sorry.
Let me go do that.
- Not from there anyway,
right?
- I wanna thank you all
for joining.
And I wanna make sure, and I hope,
that each of you from this session learned
a little bit more about AI,
and more importantly,
how you can leverage AI,
whether it's agentic or generative
in helping to solve
your business problems.
If you're interested
in learning more about
how Kyndryl can help you,
you can visit booth 1475
or you can register for
an agentic AI workshop
using the QR code.
So I wish everyone a
wonderful rest of your day
and enjoy AWS re:Invent,
and thank you for taking
time with us today.
(audience clapping)